right now we turn to the phone lines and
we have a one of the greats
in the history of uh ufc he is the
heavyweight champion of the world after
taking care of
uh dc daniel cormier over the weekend he
is back here on the show
uh stipe miocic the pride of euclid ohio
on the phone line how are you sir
good to see how you doing i am doing
fine congratulations
on the win this place we appreciate that
thank you thank you you are very
how you feeling everything good you're
fine yeah you know a little beat up you
know just like a
uh you as you would feel funny 25
minutes but overall i feel pretty good
okay good what is it like fighting dc i
mean when you're when you're going to be
looking back on this years from now what
what do you think that's like uh
you know stuff just because you know
he's a gamer he's an amazing competitor
great fighter uh he brings a lot of
aspects to the game you know and so
yeah you always gotta evolve especially
fighting him three times so it's like
every
every campus a little bit the same but a
lot different in many ways
right and um and what does it mean for
you
to be the heavyweight champion um
of this sport and having successfully
defended your title
four times stipe which is something i
don't know uh if anybody's going to be
able to
uh beat eventually
yeah it means a lot you know it means uh
not just me but my coaches and
you know teammates everyone's helped me
along the way you know it's a group
effort it's not
it's not just me you know i know i go in
there and you know someone exciting but
it's
just behind the scenes of everyone
putting in the work making the
sacrifices
with my coaches leaving their families
you know my wife and you know watching
my daughter and taking care of me at the
same time making sure i'm
eating right and doing the right thing
and you know just
you know just it's just you know i'm
just so happy you know everything's
worked out
now obviously you've you've been there
and done that and you keep doing it
what is it like doing this during a
pandemic stipe what
what is the protocol like for you
well i don't think the book for dummies
is how to you know
train during a pandemic but i think we
did pretty good you know uh
it was uh you know it was at times it
could have been hard but you know we
we made it work it was great and you
know we luckily the gyms are open
after a week or two after i found a
contract so that worked out well for us
in my basement which i didn't want to
it's one thing i'd never wanted to do
and i did but actually i think it was a
blessing
in disguise because i got to spend more
time at home i actually got to put my
daughter in bed so i wasn't training at
night when i got home she was already
sleeping so actually
it was awesome how old's your daughter
she just turned two
she just turned two oh my gosh yeah
oh savage
[Laughter]
i mean so so what's her name
well i mean this is what what do you
think your daughter's
going to learn about you and the the way
that you go about your business what do
you want her to know
when she grows up and understands what
you have just accomplished and what
you're accomplishing stipe
uh i wanted to know that hard work pays
off
you know everything's earned never given
and that i did it all for her
all for her and um so a little bit more
kids than men too
no i know i know i hear you um
i know and and so i guess that's that's
the some of the questions i want to ask
you about and a lot of fans want to know
is is the future um it looks like jon
jones is uh
targeting uh some sort of match up with
you uh
having vacated uh his current position
and saying he wants to go heavyweight
what are your thoughts on that subject
yeah man listen i'm down to fight anyone
that's what i always say
but right now i just want to hear up and
just enjoy life for a change you know
you know
and absolutely enjoy my family and my
wife my daughter enjoy the pool and that
work out in it for a change
just want to you know love life
so um who do you think deserves a shot
at you
uh i mean there's a lot of guys i mean
your friends is looking great
so he's uh he's on a tear and you know
he's completely give you the next
contender but you're awesome there's jon
jones you have a super fight so you know
like if i was a matchmaker i wouldn't be
funny so i mean i don't know
what the ufc wants so what what do you
want from uh
the ufc i mean how many fighters do you
have left are you happy with your deal
with ufc right now
sleeping yeah yeah i know for sure i'm
uh yeah i'm just you know just like i
said just want to relax right now for
like you know a week or two and not be
bothered but
you know fight questions now like you
guys just find time like when the ufc is
gonna like they'll
heal up and just make sure i'm good to
go and then uh
you know and just enjoy life for a
change okay so does that mean the brown
season is that what that means the
cleveland brown season
it's coming up oh yeah for sure i can't
wait i'm excited
okay um what do you think about the new
coach
and everybody there stephen do you think
you've got it actually
a lot actually yeah there's something
about a man he's got the mentality of
like you know
you know he's like screw everyone i
think everyone thinks i'm not going to
do well and then you know kind of just
show it back in the face and you know
but yeah we got great players so
just gotta put it go together that's how
it is okay have you uh met baker
mayfield have you had that uh
conversation with him at any point in
time
yeah another night i can't think about
it a great guy and his wife they're the
great people
and you know miles also
okay so their first game is at baltimore
uh we're looking at it right here and
then home against cincinnati what are
you what are you calling for your
cleveland browns season
it's calling deep amyochic mean
better than last year of course you know
i believe
we can definitely win more than eight
games okay all right
so you think they're gonna go um nine
and seven ten and six which would be
quite a season yeah
for the for for the cleveland browns
steve bamiochi here
on the rich eisen show are you still are
you still um
fighting fires with the valley view fire
department stipe are you still doing
that or you're taking
i work i work tomorrow what do you mean
so when you say you work tomorrow walk
me through
so what do you mean well you're
part-time so i pick my schedule in
advance and uh well
i pick you know tomorrow you know last
month i picked it you know working 24
tomorrow
so you know go into 7 30 and leave the
next day at 7 30.
so just so i understand um you are
crowned again uh winning by unanimous
decision
you defend your title you are undisputed
ufc
heavyweight champion of the world you
win in
uh ufc 252 and
a handful of days later with you healing
up you're gonna go
spend a shift at the valley view fire
department full 24 hours
correct why
ain't no different nobody you know hard
work pays off and yeah i worked hard to
shoot my firemen also okay um
in terms of because i i've been around
many fire departments and i know the
way that uh you know firefighters
sometimes uh
uh deal with one another is there any
sort of uh
you know lack of better phrase hazing
that goes down where you get some sort
of treatment from
veterans that doesn't matter that you're
a ufc champion
stipe does that happen oh yeah i'm going
to get destroyed tomorrow sorry
mentally prepare for it tonight what do
you mean you're going to get destroyed
what is that i mean what way
please make me do things that are just
you know embarrassing like you know
clean the toy with the belt on
you know mop the floors i mean just just
make me stand up from the apron and wave
to people with the belt on just
some stuff and then it's fun though
because one thing i learned in the
department if they don't make funny or
they don't like you that's true
that's true it's good that it's good to
get that sort of that's true
so you're gonna have your championship
belt on
cleaning toilets at some point tomorrow
is that what you're saying
no i'm actually i'm not going to bring
it in
i'm not going to play but it's not going
to happen tomorrow that will not happen
tomorrow
okay that's one thing that will not
happen tomorrow but uh but
you know heaven forbid if somebody you
know does need um
you know help you you will be
potentially out there
fighting a blaze if necessary tomorrow
just within days of having vanquished uh
dc that's a possibility
that is amazing 100 that is truly
amazing do you have anything you want to
say about dc if this is this it does
appear to be his last fight stephen is
there anything you'd like to
put out there on the record about um
about fighting him as
many times as you did yeah it was an
honor it was honor having a trilogy with
him it was an honor
stepping in the afghan with him he's an
amazing fighter like i've been saying
always an amazing ambassador
the guy has a great resume of not just
fighting with wrestling and everything
he's a great commentator
and i wish him nothing but the best uh
the family's having another baby in
october which is amazing so god bless
and with that and i wish nothing but the
best nothing but the best to you too sir
i was enjoyed i mean uh what'd you think
of the billions episode we shot together
in that fight with dollar bill and mafia
what did you think of the best show of
every shot
that's whatever that was a blast that
day on that set
don't you think that was great it was so
much fun i had great times
i know and then especially when we were
on the set that day
it was just a a couple of was that a
couple weeks after
wilder and fury fought for the first
time and fury got up off the
off the the canvas and what were the
conversations you had with wilder at
some point
during that day okay you know what's
funny is that i saw
one time throughout the whole day that's
it yeah
when we started when did we do the
boxing match yeah and we talked a little
bit nothing
nothing crazy hey man what's going on
there's talking no one's next fight you
know good luck and just you know
just being tummy nothing you know
nothing out of the ordinary you know
great guy nice guy
he's very very you know very very very
supposed to talk to you
i know and unfortunately it kind of gave
us a little bit of a glimpse of what
it's like to fight in front of no fans i
mean what what ha
what is that like for you right now as
we wrap up our conversation here
fighting within you know it with nobody
in there sorry
no go for it please mike
well it was uh you know it i think it
was gonna be awkward and then when i
walked in like oh this is kind of
awkward
because usually there's like 15 000 fans
screaming and
all that craziness and you know it was
nice nothing anyone you suck or you're
gonna get knocked out so that was kind
of nice
um but you know overall it was weird but
the minute i stepped in the ass kind of
it was game on you know it was a fight
and it stands or not you know but
i love the fans there you know i don't
just because you know they make a sport
what it is of course
we wouldn't be we're rad it wasn't for
them well i've walked the streets of new
york with you stipe and none of those
fans that say you suck were certainly
around you and i've been around you i
would never dare say that to your face
i'll tell you that i'm a lover not a
fighter
well congratulations on uh on the fight
and uh
enjoy the love that you're getting from
your family um and
um and the tough love i guess that
you're gonna get from the valley view
fighter
uh fire department uh over the next 24
hours and thanks for the call let's do
this again real soon
yes sir thanks for having me always
thank you that's steep amiocic
the ufc heavyweight champion of the
world hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here